pay more attention because we're going
live now so um all that gossip you were
passing on to Alex needs to
stop yes you're definitely a woman and
drag I haven't even started made
you sleep for a
week
public
G okay so we're we're live
and David you're first up have a have a
seat in front of you there get control
of that microphone we have 10 minutes
for each speaker so um it's a bit of a
balancing act if you do it less than 10
minutes then you'll open up some time
time where the councilors might ask you
some questions so welcome anyway my name
is David
Swan um I'm a resident of
bluff I looked at the proposals for
esque place and as I always do as a
project manager I kind of I'm interested
in the pros and cons and then I go to
look at the um the preferred option
and the preferred option makes no
sense um if you read the pros and cons
of
um the options um option two stands out
it has one con and lots and lots of pros
and look I'm a project manager um I've
been an army officer I know how to do
appreciations I know how to do an
analysis of of factors and when I I see
something that doesn't make sense it
kind of makes me wonder what other
factors aren't actually presented in
here that allowed those pros and cons to
be weighed very differently to what's in
the um in in this um
submission
so I've Had The Good Fortune to travel
the world um I know great public spaces
when I see them great public spaces do
not have tour buses um running through
the center of them um
most great public spaces around the
world are now
pedestrianized and this public place
should be
pedestrianized um I'm really sorry if
the distinction Hotel requires um more
space for tour buses than um their
selected side allows but sorry that
isn't consideration that makes a great
public space um this space needs to
remain entirely
pedestrianized and I see nothing wrong
with option two so I think that's really
I I I won't waste any more of your time
what's wrong with option two that has
led that not to be the council's
preferred option so you're not wasting
your time um uh when we had a bit of a
straw vote when we put the initial
submission out we we had to sort of um
show a preferred option which was option
one having said that there was only a
one councelor difference in the in the
levels of voting so there was probably a
pretty reasonable even uh split so it's
good to hear from people about what
might tip our mind one way or other so
the council doesn't have a preferred
option just for one okay but we are
required to declare that okay go
Tom David did I mishar you when you
started at first I thought you said that
um option three made no sense did I miss
you meant option option one made no
sense okay yeah okay option three is
okay but I can see it has a lot of
issues around private um uh easements
and so on so option two seem to make
perfect sense thank you
apologies other
questions
there uh thanks Fe submission and no
it's not a waste of our time at all um
my question is did you realize that
walkner place is still technically a
road how can I how can I respond I there
are lots of um technical roads from a
survey perspective around um
RT um frankly whether a road is
technically um a a a paper Road or a a
formed road is is immaterial um there's
a drive excuse the pun for
pedestrianized um City spaces as far as
possible and so if it's if it if it's a
technical matter I I can't understand
why that would be a
consideration thank you
liy thanks for your submission
David just to invite you to expand a
little bit
more your absolute preference was for
option
two would you agree that there could be
some even more improvements with option
two I think option
two with the right detailed
architecture uh with the right detailed
design has the offers the potential
potential of a worldclass public space
um I think it's the only one of the
three options that offers that potential
but I'm not I mean hey if it's done on
the
cheap it'll be as it is today which is a
disappointing public space
so thank
you questions I've only just got the one
um part of our um push to revitalize the
inner city is we've pushed away I guess
from wner and up into S3 you'll have
seen that of course um so what do you
what do you see the use cuz i' I've
checked from months on end now how many
people are actually Ling for one of the
B words in and around walking the place
and there's you can count them on one
hand over weeks and weeks and weeks
everybody tends to come into the thing
so if you if you're promoting um option
two which is basically to leave it
without a road access through um what
would you see the future you use of
it
so the distinction Hotel will be a
considerable asset
to um inoc Carle no doubt about that it
is a source of uh people coming
into our
city um those people
deserve a walk from the hotel to the the
the core shopping district that is as
beautiful as possible so right there is
one sort of future aspiration to bring
the distinction hotel and of course if
the distinction Hotel hopefully has um
some great dining um and bar options
then that flow it does extend but
putting a bus route through the middle
of it um doesn't doesn't deliver to that
Vision itrs it so given your your
project management thing I I'll pose you
another question um how do you feel
about the concept of um the opportunity
of not having bus access through there
but taking out the clock structure and
what have you which is very tired and
what do you think about the potential
for wind tunneling and stuff like that
so that's where the detailed design
comes in so first of all i' I've got no
particular love of the clock except that
it is something that
a lot of locals seem to to love so
almost in that case why not refurbish it
why take it down but um the detail
design is the is where the placement of
trees placement of of of other
structures will alleviate any wind
tunneling effect um because it's that
that makes it a an unusable space right
now okay thank you for that any other
questions
counselors no you really
right on 10 minutes as well which is
great Brian where have you
are you're welcome uh yeah my name is
Brian Dunley uh my parents moved here in
the early 80s for my dar's job and they
never left and I grew up to school here
and I've been and gone and moved all
over the world and I actually agree with
what he said about public spaces not
having tour
buses um so the first one my big issue
is that the consultation options control
the outcome because there no option to
disagree with the
options and all the options for the
first part about walking the place means
that the hotel is having tour buses
through and I don't think there should
be tour buses going through there at all
it should be pedestrian
and the issue with the clock is that
it's not so much the bells that I care
about because they can be modernized to
do bird songs or something but it's
about the clock but they're amazing
piece of
mechanical work and they seem to be
disappearing uh the bit about the mall
is that it's corporate welfare and that
you shouldn't do it and if the mall can
stand on its own float the mall and then
people can buy shares and they can raise
their own Capital that way to pay off
debt and with the
cctvs I don't have an issue with CCTV
I'm I'm I'm I'm hesitant about what's
done with the information while it's
captured and if facial recognition is
used in the CBD who has access to the
information and the flow and effects of
that and how we need to ensure that
people are open and aware of that and
what's going to happen with that data
that's all I have to say really okay so
I can probably help you with the letter
which is your CCTV and just draw your
attention that we've recently adopted a
um very extensive document that's the
policy around that so you just can't
walk in off the street or Council can't
get access to the imagery that comes
with CCTV outside agencies well I mean
you you you couldn't come in and say I
want to have a look at a piece of that
TV shot down the street I I was down
there I mean there'll be um very strict
controls around who can access I can't
walk in and just have a have a look at
the what's been played out there police
obviously have access um and so and some
of our key staff will have but the
document is is very detailed around
privacy rights how long you retain the
information who has access how long they
have access for um so if you get get
your hands on that document it'll answer
all the questions you need to know about
the CCTV it's on the website sorry it's
on the website um that's a technical
question I'm not sharp of those cons one
of the items Consulting on there so we
hav't oh so I'm corrected now that's one
of the things that we're still
Consulting on so we haven't finalized it
yet um so you you'll see that come out
yep cool questions counselors well hands
up
everyone K thank you for coming and
presenting to us um I'm really
interested in your comments about the
technical and you um The Disappearance
of mechanical
clocks um is it something that you have
a passion about and an interest in so
can you tell me what is unique about
ours that we should know from my
experience DAV around the country one of
the few places with a big mechanical
clock that still works like that I can't
think of anywhere else there has a clock
like that per se in like a square idiot
in a square area there's a few of them
have got them in the roundabouts like we
used to have yes yeah so having it as a
center point it's sort of of a Dying
methodology and Technology to a degree
as well like it's getting I taught I
used to teach and it's getting it's hard
to teach kids how to read analog clocks
you know so because it's they're not
seen and they're not used as useful
whereas they're all being taken away so
they're not being seen and it's part of
what you think we would lose this
insight into
the mechanics the working of it which is
which is what makes it special as well
you can actually look inside of it thank
you yep Lely thanks Brian for your
submission um you said on the S Street
West wner Place matter that there was
no there was no no Change
option but you're obviously saying don't
put two of buses through
there so if it's left in its current
pedestrian
state would
you would you approve some refreshing of
the space Oh Yeah totally yeah yeah and
what what would you see as being useful
things to refresh it integrate modern
technology you can still like park
benches that have got self they've got
solar panels on them to charge to charge
Sol to charge phones so give people
reason to go there and sit there you've
got all these food places opening up
with the mall and all that so get them
outside sitting somewhere with a purpose
to go there to charge their phones cuz
everyone has a phone free
Wi-Fi some trees and Gardens I'm not an
expert in that area
so would you say at the moment it's it's
not acting as a Public
Square it could be a lot
better A lot
better when was it acknowledged when was
it like I don't even know I can't
remember when it was built I remember
when the columns were built but I can't
remember when the walk the place was
built I may not been born
199 so you know
19 not not not as old as you think thank
you
right with respect to your um CCTV
question what who are you worried about
having access to
it everyone and anyone it's to do with
the fact Jo public uh so Joe public to a
degree but people that may have reasons
that aren't for the official reasons we
see a lot of hacks happening these days
we see we see the information being held
for ransom yeah you know and it's
something that
people so it's a security it's a
security issue and knowing that if I'm
out and about and in theago that
information safe yeah not that I'm doing
anything that anyone shouldn't want to
look at for any reason yeah it's just
that no one should be able to take that
information and then do what they want
with it because video manipulation is a
huge part of how we get our images and
get we get our views and you don't
really see the whole video you see the
parts of it people want to show you yeah
and that can CH and that can change the
opinion of what happened yeah yeah so
that's my issue with it's not the fact
that you have it because it's important
it's how it's used and used
appropriately thank it's good further
questions
caners no no no none at all thank you
very much thank
much all right Bob and I take you're
bringing Liz with you you're
not welcome 10 minutes this will be a
challenge certainly challenged I've got
some Bits of Paper I'd like someone to
hand
out are they the email
graphs I think I'll Stand Up see if I
can make sense of this put your
microphone up
oh CL counselors
staff U members of the media and members
public my submission um ignore
submissions ignore the finance for the
block and the cameras and I do not
support any of the three counil the
options for E Street West andw the
place how's that y That's fine right
um in my opinion they don't provide
access adequate access for buses and nor
and we do not need play
spaces walk to placees seldom been a
good community meeting space Dawn Street
is a better option for community events
on a Friday evening in September the
vehicles were stopped in Dawn Street and
a popular food truck event was held
there there was less wind in Dawn Street
and it doesn't have the noise and
pollution from heavy Vehicles which wner
place
has so um my submission begins with a DE
to dream and ask you each to be part of
a team working with locals to build a
good
product now you've got in front of you I
hope um P of stuff but anyway keeping
track of paper is one of my
challenges um anyway you've got yeah
you've got
the
yeah I'll get back can you give me one
we've got some St right anyway so the
option one just shows what
um uh we were given and I'm proposing
saying that this is prepared by
Consultants but they're not
locals um and they propos with a number
five there that they going to convert a
building into an information place but
as far as I know that building's now aru
has been for quite a
while um and it proposes you see what
I'm talking
about and then there's a connection into
the toara from what was what is walk the
place but it's actually into the
reception to go upstairs to the building
so you can actually just go around the
corner and go in a door that's already
there under Randa so that doesn't make a
lot of sense the right of way which
someone was keen on for um the buses to
go in is actually over private land so
um that's actually not crash
good
um and so yeah so that's what my plan
ISS well I've looked at the plans and so
the plan that I've drawn and labeled
I've shown some foot paths I've shown
some oneway vehicle paths and I've shown
some and I'm saying
that south of the or near the pizza
place there's room to sit there still in
the sun there's room to sit outside the
toilets on the other side of when it's
the weather's okay um and I think the
whole place should be turned into just
the normal street we don't need a play
space or expensive Paving or other
things that is proposed in this and so
I've drawn the mensies sorry the
converted Menses there with the number A
on it with a DOT dotted canopy outside
where the buskin park and let people
into the hotel and I'm arguing that um
if we're being civilized we welcome
people in the front door and we proba
try and keep them warm and
welcome and then I point out that was a
four level car park across the road now
some people in their submissions think
that we were trying to get into the
library car park but there hasn't really
been adequate information well well it's
confusing there's so much information I
don't know how you guys cope um but
that's another whole problem um anyway
there a car park over the road four
levels for 120 car Parks there's an
existing office building north of that
which is going to get converted into
apartments and storage you I've
handwritten aat on there out out in the
um in D Street I've got three C's which
is in fact where the columns are um
which I think should be
retained and then there's a d is the
Railway
Hotel um e is the melp building which is
being retained and converted into
apartment and storage f is the existing
building converted into apartments and
services for hotel patrons and um G is
the existing walkner Place restroom and
accessible toour which I believe should
be retained and now I've got to go back
to my notes and so um the dream that I'm
hoping you guys get part of is that well
tell you for any building I know bit
about buildings um a welcoming entrance
a sheltered and welcome entrance is
desirable for all
buildings um for many people their first
visit distinction Hotel on S Street will
be when they get off a bus now it's no
surprise but sometimes in the Carle the
weather's not good
in in my proposal the
bus exit door will be sheltered by the
private by the driver under bus cover
and then the adjacent North facing entry
door to the hotel will offer a
welcome buses are large and need space
to turn my proposed two-way s Street
traffic plan has a simple left turn from
D Street into s Street West a simple
left turn from s Street West onto D
Street the four Celtic columns stand out
in our Flat City and provide a a
pedestrian connection across the street
the Celtic columns remind us of our
Celtic or Scottish Heritage and there's
no good reason to remove
them the restrooms should also be
retained they are necessary in a time of
need um this need is great if you've
been traveling or as we get
older my traffic plan could be completed
for a fraction of the cost included in
the council's budget my dear to dream
ask this Council to consider the
different options in EST Street West I
look forward to your
questions thanks
that
God Slow Hands Up one at Time Peter I'll
go down the
line yes thank you
Bob yes I agree with you that the
pillars should be
retained um but one thing I'd like to
see there is tubular
lighting is this a question yes is
coming to a question I'll deal with this
I would like to see that uh for special
occasions and events like matariki
Christmas Easter Chinese New
Year any of that you don't understand
that I'm just asking I'm saying I don't
think it should be a public place and I
think it these streets Dawn Street's a
better option now and I think sometime
we should do a better one never going to
be successful there I'm talking about
the pillar
well would you like to see no lighting
over there no okay next question
is in my early day as a young
teenager low E Street was open to the
public until probably
19 for public Thor Affair for traffic up
until about 1986 87 or something I used
to go down there three or four times
every day of the week going to the uh
New Zealand uh
rails uh uh office dropping off parcels
and it was the most windiest place
that's what I'm saying don't put people
there are you arguing my
case it was the most windiest place in
the and the bank Corner was second worst
why am I done this you using at my time
I'm not here to argue I'm just telling
you what it was like days
hang he has the right to say that he's
already supported your position what
he's asking for is what what are what
questions do you have of him he he
doesn't want to comment on what
statement you okay should be there since
uh walk a place was was built the way it
is now into a place there hasn't been
any problems with winds that existed
prior to the the building of Walkley
place I don't believe there true 100%
true thank
you next Tom was a question yeah I'm
getting the tress don't have to laugh to
Alex you done the same two weeks ago we
don't Peter did actually partially ask
the question I was going to ask because
it does I I I know that you were an
architect involved in the um you know
the early stage of this so my my
question which is also about wind is to
the extent to which um you know that is
a myth at the extent to which it is true
that the you know the closure of the
street with a glass screen was designed
specifically for as a Windbreak uh or
did that story developed later so I'm
asking use original Architects one one
of them I was on the committee that
employed The Architects I chose to not
put my architect hat on because I wanted
to have a say in who got the job I was
Keen to get locals on and we got them
but um my experience of solid
wall um wind breaks is the wind goes
over the top of them it doesn't know
about it's got vertical Dimensions it
comes over the top and with low pressure
on the other side it bangs down harder
but in fact it's not not a solid wall
because there's doors on both ends of it
my proposal is we just cut an 8 m hole
in the middle of the where the clock
tower raised platform is and you drive
through there both ways and there's
still a where the current stage is
that's still sheltered there and on some
days it'll still be Shel on the other
side but it's not a it's inherently a
bad place for a local event and that's a
lot to do with the argument that the
number number six State Highway goes
straight past and it's noisy and it's
pollution so if I can just so you saying
Bob that um that the story that the
purpose of that glass separator original
purpose was a Windbreak is that not the
case well I I don't believe so I don't
know really I mean okay there was dozens
of people involved in that whole process
but let me tell you there's been very
few occasions in the last 24 years that
it's been a popular public place I mean
someone's put some pictures up recently
of um something to do with the shooting
in Christ Church and down there's a few
people there but we actually don't have
a decent place and that's I'm not trying
to design the future but I'm trying to
say let's not waste money there and save
some and make a decent place somewhere
some other time but spending money on
this is not
good thank
you next down that line rangy thanks
chair well hey look this is
great set of refreshing eyes on this
problem hey with the entrance and exit
on to D you looking at a slip lane typ
thing you just sort of oh know well
maybe I don't know I'm not designing it
that's maybe should have some trafficing
Engineers involved which we don't seem
to have had so far right and the other
thing is what sort of traffic caling
speed are you looking for that road
obviously you don't want people using
the road that aren't going to you know
no what my VI is you make it a decent
road yeah and you have 4 M wide Lane
each way yeah but if it gets to be a
problem then you block it somehow but
I'd do it all now in one go so that's
the cheap way to do it so that drawing
yes uh shows your exit Lane your
entrance Lane is being separated by a we
or is that just a a we what like
a no no no that's that's where the
seting still is it might it might
actually survive the art okay right
down
right this but down
here runs right the middle I think
he's well that's just to separate the
lanes yeah no no that's no that's right
and so I think that the foot path and
the road should be at the same level so
you can with a with a concrete curb
that's sort of a drive over curb which
defines where pedestrians go but if
people want to drive down a driveway or
whatever and a taxi or whatever they can
do so no looks great hey thank you very
much
Trish thanks Bob I appreciate the effort
you've G to and the thought you've
obviously put behind us my question is
why would you want an exit road going
north of D Street well some of the
people that come out of this 120 carpart
building possibly want to go
north and and other people do and this
whole area is not a high density
activity I mean although there's going
to be you know 220 people in the hotel
sometimes they're not going to be in and
out very often I mean Jeff's hoping that
they're going to stay there for a few
days it's not it's not a high pedestrian
count area and we don't need a you know
so I don't think that's an issue and and
so I so but I think it should be a
two-way street I didn't want to get into
it but someday our local buses might go
down there I mean we haven't actually in
our big thinking in the last few years
got round to thinking about our buses
local buses very well there's all sorts
of things and so somewhere my detailed
stuff I've written that you need places
for
people you know for vehicles to go
around I mean if people come from the
airport how do they get there and how do
they get out and how it's we're used to
roads it's sort of fashionable to have
cycle ways
and but vehicle things still pretty
useful and most of us I mean who who got
who came here on their
bike
um you're all provided with convenient
car packs just across the road you know
we're a car dominate Society this isn't
a proposal to get an International
magazine for
Paving y um have you considered what it
would be like for the people from the
hotel coming from the hotel into our um
Central City whatever when there are two
roads there no they they can come up the
foot path I've drawn that yeah I see
that but it's they can come up the foot
path and cross across the bus lane
that's going to get five buses through
it a day maximum yeah exactly so it's
not a big deal oh okay thank you very
much appreciate it other
questions the late an just question Bob
um why are they Celtic
columns I like them don't get me wrong
but why well John M's coming on later
you can ask him all right he was part of
the designer but um and I know someone
else is going to go on about The Columns
of wisdom um so better be careful with
what you take down though
oops just your we'll do it at
nighttime yeah one of the things we did
in this vibrant City thing which I sort
of argued at the end of my longer paper
is we have to get people involved we
have to have local people involved and
we've had lots of consultants in the
last few years that sort of fly in and
fly out and they actually aren't that
sharp on quite a few
things
EV um yes K look I'm a little bit
puzzled as to why we are so obsessed
with buses and cars and so
not talking about people in this
particular design that you're putting
forward because for those people who
move around the city on foot which is
particularly common in that es Street
area the in
reintroduction of traffic coming out of
es Street onto D Street is actually
um quite a challenging thought because
the use we have
of lower es street is different than it
was the eies that we have there now for
example the fact that
um people have gotten accustomed to a
more pedestrian friendly side of D
Street doesn't seem to Bear into the
discussion that you're having so I'm
interested in your thinking about that
well my thinking is exactly the same as
May Clark's if you have a look there
there very few people actually use the
place a few people go across and use the
food places and sometimes there's a
couple of people sitting outside there
I'm proposing that we increase the size
of that outside space there a little bit
and although I've drawn a straight line
around there for my vehicles cuz when
I'm cutting cab that's my limit but
it'll probably actually have a curve in
it you know and so there'll actually be
more space outside there um but it's
it's a myth that it's going to be a
popular place that people want to go
I I'm not sure that you quite understood
what I was saying is
that people use it not just to go and
sit but as a safe way to move along D
Street
between um Clyde Liv Street little
Street you know Clyde Street
um part of the street cresant down
towards the library things like that I
think it'll be a less busy intersection
than intersection with d and space
Street um or many of the others along
there and as I've already proposed you'd
be better off going and using these Dawn
Street whereas a it's a T intersection
and it's blocked off more and so it's
less windy and it's relatively easy to
block it off if you want to have a
public space and we're not actually
short of spaces in the new um develop
newly developed s Street for people to
do things
so a light controlled intersection then
it's like no change it's light
controlled intersection
now so Bob I just have one question I
know we've run over time so whoever's
ringing the bell in the background will
probably ring it again um just I was
interested in the wind stuff um I worked
in me e for about 10 or 15
years if one of the options we went to
which was to retain the space but not
have a road through it
but we wanted to open it up for foot
traffic to come from the new hotel
through the a street which is what we
want as well so it's not all about buses
I could be but it's not um we want
people to come out of the hotel and feel
as though they can transition across and
into e stre that's what it's all about
um is it reasonable that with with
things like trees and other things to
cut down that wind impact as opposed to
what's there at the moment excuse me I
don't want to I was laughing um it's
sort of a bit of a myth that trees do
anything I mean I I've taken progo over
the last little while the trees have
actually got no vegetation well until
recently they've had no vegetation on
them and so a few branches thicking up
in the air waving at things is a bit of
a joke okay I mean it's it's
landscapers trees look good on Plants
but they're actually no
use excellent any more
questions thanks
Bob apprciate thanks for bringing your
secretary
along Jenny I see you right at the back
there
somewhere give the next one
up where is
she how are you
welcome
jny may be small but it's very precious
welcome about 10 minutes Jimmy and we
better or that one yeah yeah as speak as
I got you got so you got about 10
minutes and we'll have some questions
for you as well okay um I'd just like to
say how significant I realized what in
the place was in my life I live in
mossburn and I don't come to inago very
often but I've been down here using it
um as meeting places um eating using the
toilet and the restroom when I'm
catching buses and um I've realized that
I've actually been to lots of um musical
events there um boo places that you know
when you've had those stalls and um
protests and often we've gathered there
to walk to the city council for various
reasons to tell the council what we felt
about certain thing that was on your
agenda or whatever or after a protest
being able to go there and reflect on
what had happened so um I thought it was
important that I participated in this
process as a as a rate payer here and a
through southlander now um I'd like to
have the area having uh one lane um
Street coming in from D Street and
turning left so that it's not
interrupting with the traffic there
after The Pedestrian Crossing and I'd
like to keep the columns I think they've
been put up for a reason and and their
significance needs to be
explained and um in light of that it
gives plenty of space for people to
continue to use that area as um the
former um submitter was talking about
people having access to that area and um
remembering that we're now into active
transport mode so cycling um there I say
skateboarding and lots of walking for
people is the new way of looking at our
city and it being easily accessible
there could be a pedestrian Crossing um
within W the place itself obviously we'd
have to take down the glass panels and
the um clock with and the clock could be
reinstated somewhere else within the um
area uh also talking about the trees
they obviously need lots of care and
attention but I think having flowers and
um trees appropriate trees uh especially
natives is to cut down our carbon
emissions and show how significant it is
to have shade and um shelter in there
and um having one lane would mean
there's more room for accessing for
people to be there I want to make sure
the toilets are kept and the restroom in
particular is a place for us to wait
when we're going on the bus and
hopefully there'll be more of the bus
services um going to areas further north
um so that people can be using that
along with trains of course which are
hopefully going to happen um I'd like to
see the area beautified um and one of
the processes could be using local
artists and with them changing college
students Mari art um especially tang
fenua and um also having interpretation
panels so to explain the significance of
the historical part of wner place and
why it became wner place in the
beginning um I think I've just about
covered all the points I wanted to make
that's right uh but the buses that were
that are coming in from d Street would
then only turn left onto esque street so
they're not cutting across the um
traffic I've been there several times
and it's quite busy that 11 Street um
section so C cutting across traffic um
there wouldn't be that option for buses
and was me as was mentioned there won't
be a lot anyway but there will be
private cars coming to stay at the new
developments in that space um in es
Street West and um and also places if
you you had angle parking as opposed to
parallel parking would allow for more
space in there as well so hopefully with
no um parking meters you know a limited
time you could have for free which I've
noticed as a country person coming into
town nowhere for me to park
anymore anyway U those are my made
points order to make Koto thank you uh
I'll take the first question with you
Jenny um I guess we we've got a balance
between uh trying to create some not
necessarily bus access but some con
connectivity between the new hotel
coming through the a street because a
street is what we've developed so that's
one issue but the other issue is that
there is
some volumes of level in the community
think that we should still retain wner
as a a place
of um place of reside or place of
staying I guess so I just wanted your
views on on on the lat on that because
at the moment I mean OB done some very
rule of thumb checking every time it a
nice warm day I go down to air Street I
see 30 or 40 people there but then I
cross over to walkon there's nobody
there and I think most of the people
that use the food Outlets either buy it
and eat it in the outlets or they buy it
and take it away so I just wonder you
know if you wanted to retain and you
said you were keen on having still
having some ability in that area what
would need to change to make that more a
place where people would um be as
opposed to coming into EST stre and and
using all the seting is there as well I
think that's what I was talking about
the artwork and um uh having having some
more interpretation panels and things to
look at and so on we've got really good
um at explaining some of the stories of
our city and I've just come from a
Heritage South meeting planning Heritage
Month next March so that could be you
know if we got it up and running or
maybe we could have a gathering there
and ask people about stories like I've
told you today about what's taken me to
walk the place and why people gather
there so um I think you know we could
look around lots of parks and that we
have in in in the Carland they're not
used constantly but people use them um
when they have free time they meet
friends there on a nice sunny day and um
having trees and beautifying it with um
not thousands of dollars worth of
landscaping but you know being mindful
of of our environment in general is
changing changing and we have to be up
with it making sure that we've got trees
for carbon um absorption or um dealing
with carbon emissions and modeling um
different ways of being as in biking and
walking and less emphasis on cars and
and buses so just another not sure if
that meets your um that's all that's all
good just one other quick question and
given that you're a mature age like I am
um back in the day we used to have the
eyesight Center in as part of the museum
and that attracted a lot of people who
wanted to know where to go and at this
stage we don't have a replacement for
that in the city so given that we got
two big hotels sitting right in the
middle of our city now is walkner a
place to have an eye center an eyesight
Center where people wanting to know what
to do in and around the city and tours
they can go on yeah maybe a kiosk with
um you know not too big that's a thing
because you've got other things in there
as I said that you can feature sure yeah
and especially if that's just arriving
from out of Town having somewhere
immediately they can get to um and I
think that's even having more
information in that visitors restroom in
the toilet area is quite handy where you
can sit down there and read pamplet and
look at things that you can do around
the city there's a lot going on here yep
okay questions
Lesly thanks Jenny um so you feel that
we should take down the glass panels and
the brick work and the clock and have
single Lane
exess what's your comment on the comment
of many other submitters about the wind
tunnel if we take down the glass panels
and the tower
Etc it is quite Breezy in there but then
I come from northern Southland and you
can't beat that so you know so because
because because you said you've often
used wner place I'm presuming you know
it before the glass panels were there
was it worse before they were there I
think having solid panel panels doesn't
actually cut the wind because it's
inclined to whip around the corner you
know at your G if you have a tin fence
around your garden it doesn't actually
cut the wind it goes over the top swoops
down into your garden as opposed to
having trellises or something so maybe
that um you know having that kind of
thing with roses and that over it or um
uh some of the climbing um Native things
that we can have yeah would be an
alternative to having the solid glass
panels you know would be another
option thanks Darren Council serer asked
my question about the Windbreak so let
me just uh throw this one at you Jenny
did you know I appreciate you coming
down by bus but did you know that
everybody that parks at those parking
meters gets the first half hour
free sorry the first half hour at those
parking meters is free did you realize
well just shows you I'm a country bukin
doesn't it well no you don't know unless
somebody tell you I know we're lot of
the 90m one um minute ones are now I
must admit and it allows me an hour to
go to the to a meeting and come out and
rescue my car so thank you um councilor
llo
Tom Jenny when I I read your submission
um I was pretty sure that the punch line
would be that you did not want vehicles
to go down through low his street but
you do so I I I just wonder
um will you
kind of were you taken to that point
because you felt that Council would wish
that to happen or do you actually
believes that it's a good thing for
vehicles to be allowed down a stre cuz
just rest your submission seems to be so
so defensive of um of walk the place
that it was a surprise
to to read that punch line I was quite
surprised myself when I started
writing how how it's um quite a IAL
place with memories and so on and I
wonder if other people have got those
good memories and want to build on them
as well so maybe making it more of a
feature um of the center of town which I
understand was one of the reasons it was
built and when you've got those hotels
and that around it's a nice place for
people to go and actually sit outside
yeah and I see that we're hopefully
going to do something more about the air
pollution and in the kagle as well so it
might help people sitting outside yeah
you hi
um yeah lovely to hear your stories uh
my question is really around you talked
about The Pedestrian Crossing within W
the place and but you also talked about
the increase of py and skateboarders and
now we have electric scooters and
everything else um just around safety do
you see that being an issue I mean
giving that you know that's a place
where a lot of people gather mhm having
entrance even a oneway entrance into
there do you see any sort of hazarded
around accidents War I think if there's
a pedestrian Crossing and the buses have
turned they're not going very fast and
I've just walked up Dawn Street yeah and
um realized how slowly the cars are
moving along there I was a bit doubtful
about that when I saw all that happening
but um yeah there just seems to be a
much more peaceful feel there now on
that street
and um the same with es Street yeah so
walking in Town's really good to get a
sense of how people are using the
streets and the Redevelopment that's
taken place and and if this I didn't
realize there would only be maybe five
buses a day probably in the morning in
the afternoon or whatever um but um if
they're turning then obviously they're
going slowly anyway and the pedestrians
Crossing is just an extra safety
precaution for people who are using that
um Street yeah but you also talked about
having car cars entering on that as well
I pick that
up oh cars coming that way yes I presume
there would be PE people in cars coming
into the hotel and that as well yeah I
don't know much about the new
development yest yet I I saw it last
week with it all stripped out and I
thought oh that's going to be pretty
amazing
yeah yeah thank
you any other questions
councils you're done
thank you very much for your time
appreciate your input
yeah okay Lindsay where have you
are
welcome thank you M Clark counselors
staff
public my name is Lindsay fren I've been
around this town for many years I've
been involved with many events in
inago including the New Year's Eve
family celebrations in wner
place um I believe we should be giving a
to
makeover it's now to the ti looking but
I disagree with a um bus
lane I was was looking up the internet
the other day and found a song in the
50s called um the train goes through the
middle of the house because this is the
railway
line and to me spoing walk the place by
putting the bus line
in is not right the official opening of
what the place the late n Lee made a
video I watched that video a couple
years
back I if anyone's here has looked at
the video Mia Eve Paul she was all
excited and in her words she said I can
imagine what it's going to be like
people and what in the place there'll be
music there'll be dancing and happy
people like it was in the old days so
I'm predicting she was thinking about
the Post Office Square but I don't know
now walk in the place
face I believe Mrs
wner generously was a a uh a person who
gave money to the development I'm not
too sure if it was money or land and
that's what we've got to
remember was named after her she put
money into it now I've noticed that
you've done the felbert gates up they
were donated the and Anderson's Park and
I do not
believe we should turn it into a bus
line for um Mrs mner sorry I'm getting
Tongue Tied cuz I'm
nervous and if
Mrs Paul was alive today and stole the
meor you would have to be brain dead
or um what's the other word I'm looking
for brave to come into mayor Paul's
office to suggest to her we remove the
clock to put in a bus lane she would
take a deep
breath she would hit the roof she'd have
the person's guts for GS and order them
out of the
building now Mrs wner she'll be
devastated
um I had the privilege of meeting Mrs
wner at the Ral age of 106
and this was for the the um Millennium
celebrations that we had in Walk the
place and that was through a city
councelor um e city counselor thma she
arranged for us to pick Mrs wner up from
the nursing home we bought her down she
was wrapped she thanked
us we took her back to the um home spent
some time with her what tickled my fancy
every time she spoke about her husband
she called him Mr
wner they I think we should show respect
to those two ladies and keep walk in the
place the way it is but just do it up
thank
you thank
you so I I'll leave off with a question
for you Lindsay um we've done some um
canvasing of the young people in our
city sort of 18 to 30 year olds given
that they're the Next Generation most of
most of us are too old for that um and
they were very much wanting to have uh
Street Music or I guess what they call
part Street parties with cheap food and
even cheaper alcohol if they could get
it um and we've had one of those
recently in Dawn Street and that was
part of the dream that we had to do up
Dawn and Es so um regardless of whether
whe a bus goes through or not because
that's a really contentious issue or any
exess goes through what would you do
with walkner to try and put some life
back into it other than it just being a
memorial for Mrs
Wagner well I'd suggest to rethink the
out have the BL the place from the stage
forward remove all that stuff and get
some design and make it a place for
people to meet okay updated yeah um I'm
against the clock going I remember um
one year we had the New Year's party and
we had a uh an
MC and he got all the crowd
pumping uh for the
countdown now that MC is actually
sitting here at the council table did a
great job
too BMC oh sorry at a very reasonable
price he was talking about about g r a t
e a
great yeah questions
councilors yeah Peter yeah Linda you
mentioned uh or asked the question if
Mrs mael wner donated money to walk the
place actually in fact what did happen
and Council records will show that she
gifted two Parcels of land to the city
council and hence named walkner place
now on the left going down there was a
building there called aeson's building
once that was the inago city library
before it moved to Dawn Street and over
the other side was Smith and
rainford's so both those Parcels of land
that which I've been told were gifted to
the City by mile wner so if we go with
the buses as plans of here been put
forward today that means the both
Parcels of land will be overtaken by
roadway not the old roadway but cut
across the corners of that gifted land
now to Mrs walkner after making a gift
to the city you do that to a gift what
would her friends or your friend of hers
and her relations and her descendants
think I think it would be a very sad day
for inago to put buses over gifted
land thank you Peter I agree what's your
thoughts yeah that's that's the question
what's your thoughts yeah I think the
and when you brought up the um reason
about the wind tunnel when we first
started the New Year's party and walk in
the place we put a um tooling over the
back I've got video footage of that I
watched it the other day and you can see
the tarole
and and that was rectified Lindsay after
that that's right they actually extended
the the glass piece to the north and
that fixed it that's right right yes
thank you other
questions oh EV um just a clarification
Lindsay
um is the name wner Place actually for
Mrs wner or for Mr wner because he was
the may I
mean I not diminishing her gift but it's
more the name wner that is
um has the significance that comes
from the May rather than herself well I
can't answer that you don't know the
other no um but I know if Paul was
involved in it anyway yeah no he was a
legend in our family because of his
provision of shoes to families during
the Depression so um when people and and
my grandparents talked about Abraham
wner and Mrs wner they talked about
their generosity to those who had less
and so I'm really Keen that the memory
is continued but I was just curious
whether you knew whether it was he or
she or both I um I was told that he used
to throw the shoes down the stairs if
you didn't buy
them or if you criticize them I
believe well don't throw at
me any other questions thank you Lindsay
no thank you very much for your time
thank you for hearing me out
thank
you waiting for two
others look she just
G
here here
lucky day go jump the
queue get more
time
not good
try good good afternoon and welcome um
and thank you for the opportunity of um
hearing my ideas and thoughts and uh I'd
like to make a point that I'm not alone
did get emotional sorry um hundreds of
people would agree with with the
sentiment
of what I express I put posts on
Facebook and we get likes loves positive
comments about the whole business of
preserving what we have it just seems
ridiculous to spend so much money
demolishing something that would cost $2
million to build I mean where are we
what we need is
education public education so people
have brought up to speed with what the
columns
represent are four pillars of
wisdom our
knowledge our
skill our
history and our attitude to the Future
now when you look at them they are
perfect transition from The Busy retail
area of esk street to the Tranquility of
wner
place a lot of comments about wner Place
being oh not used enough look at the
Japanese garden does anyone trample in
there no we look at it the seren of it
is
beautiful however what in the place can
still be used I was there last Wednesday
in gale force winds everywhere else in
what in a place it was calm I was able
to throw my hat into the air and catch
it it is designed to Shelter From the
Westerly wind cutting a gap in that West
Wall would be equivalent to us taking
out those windows permanently
we're told that W the place isn't used
very much why is
that we don't plan events
there how often is this room used how
often would it be used if we didn't
schedule events
here cut a gap in there don't schedule
any events here and see what happens to
the through see what would happen to the
swimming pool the Li Li the Scottish
Hall the Civic Hall if we didn't manage
events there what we need to do is ask
our staff to include walk the place as a
venue to have weekly activities that can
change so people don't get bored with
that we'd have many golf treasure hunts
for kids we could have temporary sand
things like that just try things out
people will come people will enjoy
that we can have choirs
invited to sing on
Sundays the main thing with walk the
place is don't let people hijack it all
the time we had the Starbucks there
hogging up a whole lot of space we had
the I
Center blocking off the
stage if we allow buses
in let's if we could do it somehow
miraculously windproof the Gap that they
come through you know what that means to
events no voluntary organization could
ever have an event there without a
traffic management plan you know that
cost money a lot of volunt voluntary
organizations they don't have money for
that sort of stuff they just want to be
able to say hey guys we're meeting at
wner place there's something really
important for us to protest about
pensioners need more money or something
like that that is very important in a
democracy Now have a look at the map of
inago how much space is devoted to motor
vehicles and how much spaces devoted to
pedestrians exclusively to P
pedestrians in the um City Center what
place is the only pedestrianized area
the only one we're going to trash it are
we going to allow buses through
there I don't think
so I thought it was a lone voice but so
many of the other submissions agree with
us that we need to preserve what in the
place and
instead of looking at the architecture
and the color the paint and all that
invest in
people we're coming to a Crossroads in
the whole way that we live we have
invested enough in Motor Vehicles buses
real estate now we need to invest in
people we need the events team to
coordinate events in wner place we need
the um public education force of the
council to come up to speed with telling
people what
the Celtic columns
represent thank
you so just a couple of ply questions
for you um we're putting quite a bit of
effort into events being especially over
the spring and summer months events
being in Dawn Street and E Street are
you suggesting that we add that to wner
or we take away from those areas and
focus more on
Walker well what I've noticed about
events in um in es Street and in Dawn
Street we have um temporary food
Caravans and stuff like that the first
thing they do is they Park to block off
the wind what's got that already and
there is also um we have to consider the
non-commercial aspect of things we we
we're allowing our whole lives to be
dictated by
food and we all carry too much of a
spare and alcohol there's nothing wrong
with having what in a place as an event
we just have to say that's where we're
meeting and people will
come questions counselors yeah
Peter
congratulations um you mentioned alcohol
what did you say about alcohol zero
alcohol and walk the place or do you
think we should have alcohol there on
special occasions what's your thoughts
on that
I haven't given it a lot of thought but
basically um I do drink myself but I'm
not an advocate of having um alcohol
available at every occasion I just think
we should try and steer away from that
kind of uh culture so I'd say
no like in this day and age with calf
bars and that people can dine outside
and have a a quiet drink I mean a quiet
drink a wine or something
Le thank you L's see
thanks for the submission I noticed that
you one of the things you advocate for
is making w a place more child
friendly considering that it's right
next door to a state
highway would you see the need to put up
some
barriers at that front part as part of
more child
friendly
place um possibly but I think the way it
is at the moment um that there are a
couple of plots it's a tree in the
middle of a plot and there actually
enough for room just to Chuck in a load
of sand and a few toys and the moms are
pretty Vigilant they'll be watching
their little toddlers I've seen um
little kids and what in the place for
different events before it's not a not a
big
problem and I I noticed your comment
about the Westerly
winds do you have personal experience of
walking the place before there was a
bear up there before the glass in the
clock to was put up no no but I can
imagine cuz that's something we're
always battling in Southland and and a
lot of Consultants who come into town
and draw lovely pictures of landscaping
that forget that the westle wind is
something that we have to
consider thank
you very Paul you don't um just um with
the walk place thing I mean I agree with
you on quite a few points but with the
walk the place thing is a talking to the
microphone do you not see an issue with
the traction across the road and having
across state highway want to get there
if you've got a lot of people in Walking
the place you know at a particular event
they're probably want going to want to
go across the road which is of course
leely said at state state highway six um
you don't see that as a problem because
I mean it's unfortunate that it is
disjointed by State Highway six and
because you know the attraction of
um in central if you like and the indry
the way it is at the moment you don't
see it as a possible
issue well um of course it could be an
issue um at the moment everywhere that
you look there is an issue of a toddler
running under a bus or under a car but
it doesn't happen because they tend to
be looked after
well I'm not saying that you say walk
the place oh let's get a whole lot of um
kids and just in they each child would
have a minder we might find that good
idea to put a barrier and stuff like
that but not to put too much emphasis on
construction to work out how to talk to
people and work out all these kind of
problems we seem to be putting too much
emphasis on on developing real estate
and not just
people so because I do totally agree
that there is no other place in inago
where without traffic management system
you can actually go and meet really is
the only place yeah if you do do
something this street you're right
something has to be done there are
ballers of course they can go up but
Crea straight into a mo sort of
situation but the focus you don't sort
of feel the focus has sort of changed
from walking the place really to to
across the road really to T Street in
fact with the ball that can just be
raised and suddenly the road's closed
you don't think that supports us for the
the same thing I'm not too sure whether
a track management plan will be required
that or not
I don't know myself personally what do
you think do you think would would would
that would that supplement that is what
I'm asking would that take care of that
if that was available as a a place to
use without traffic management would
that meet the requirements of what you
mentioned well possibly but what in the
place is like a room it's a natural room
the um East E Street is Corridor it's
quite different you have a meeting in a
room in the corridor you tend to drift
along from one thing to another one shop
one C to another or whatever and what in
the place is designed as an event being
so it's a matter of actually scheduling
events there inviting people to come
along and do things and there are lots
of organizations they the um the puppy
training Club they do something on a
Saturday morning they choirs and stuff
like that's it's just putting a bit of
effort into it and um okay it's going to
cost some something to do that is but
it's better to pay a salary
than um a huge amount of real estate
because these real estate projects
they're just getting Bing it's time to
draw a line in the sent say look that
enough of it that area does not need to
be made up
and um enhanced again it's already been
done once focus on a street that hasn't
been done up yet with that same amount
of resource and
funding
any other
questions oh Barry yeah I walked down e
the other day and I and I Westerly and
walking the place the barriers didn't
make any difference at all I just got
blown
over so yeah I struggle to see that the
barriers are they might be right when
you're standing right beside them they
might be fine but um walking down E
Street and westly is always a struggle
is that is that a question what's what's
the
question just I'm just telling you
effect of well well when I was there I
was quite near the stage yeah in the
area that what you'd call the mosh if
you were if there was a band going it
was great
absolutely hat went up in the air I
caught it and I've captured it on video
if you want to see it yeah I mean they
went
there was like it was 50 50 km winds
I've got a photo of the actual met
figures as well for that same time that
I threw the Hat up just as as Pro if you
if you want to see the evidence so to
speak
yes all right any other
questions thank you very much for your
time thank
you Laura wherever you are the stage is
yours
welcome about 10 minutes we'll say great
if you could use the microphone perfect
Koto K Laura Pope toing my name is Laura
Pope and I am a health promotion advisor
as part of the National Public Health
Service nphs in inago within Tatu water
I'm here to discuss with the council how
and why creating a street through wner
Place influences health and well-being a
person's health and wellbeing are not
influenced by their individual Behavior
but also factors that are situated in
their environment the built environment
is related to buildings and
infrastructure as well as land use which
are often human-made and construct the
physical world around us Studies have
shown that the built environment is able
to influence Health outcomes such as
mental health high blood pressure weight
and other heart related illnesses as a
result it is necessary to consider how
the physical environment May influence
behavior which as a result can influence
Health outcomes nphs Southern has no
preference over the financial
restructuring for City Block we do not
feel it appropriate to make a comment on
the financial implications of council
nphs supports option two people first es
connection to city center with with bus
access from liven Street option two of
the proposed change to wner place allows
for safe and active travel in an around
dist Street several times the current
document discusses a pedestrian friendly
environment a pedestrian friendly
environment is one that promotes the
public to walk and move about a space
freely without anxiousness of incoming
traffic in the master plan step number
five states that the council intend to
enable easy pedestrian and cycle access
through great connections to City Green
spaces and water I would argue the best
way way to do so for w the place would
be to make it pedestrian only not only
will it encourage movement in and around
the West End of es street but it will
prevent any harm to pedestrians from
incoming traffic option two is able to
create a supportive environment for good
well-being enabling the opportunity to
create more green spaces within the CBD
for mental health and H water Urban
green spaces can promote physical and
mental health reduce morbidity and
mortality by relieving stress and
stimulating social
cohesion if Council are able to create
an opportunity to provide more green
spaces that are accessible in and around
the CBD they will help to maintain good
well-being inago is a relatively windy
place and currently walk a place has a
wind barrier this prevents highspeed
winds from tunneling all the way from
all the way to esque Street and removes
any unpleasantness for pedestrians to
remove the wind barrier for the purpose
of of a road is likely to cause
significant winds from one side of esk
to the other we do not support option
one in the implementation of a road for
the purpose of tour buses a concern when
creating a road for the purpose of tour
buses is that there is likely a risk of
other undesignated vehicles using the
road also known as R running there are
four key concerns surrounding the
potential of rat running including
increased traffic noise increase
pollution and built up and bu builtup
areas congestion and safety concerns
each of these negatively affect
well-being to The Pedestrian and other
Road users climate change is a
responsibility that we all need to be
accountable to the climate change act
2019 has set the priority that New
Zealand will reduce their emissions to
Zero by
2050 we encourage Council as a local
authority to take this as a priority and
consider consider how each of your
decisions make an impact on climate
change it is misunderstood that creating
a road will provide more space for
current drivers to spread out and make
roads less
congested it has been found that the
more roads equate to more cars and as a
result more emissions therefore by
creating a road it is likely you'll be
contributing to more emissions creating
a road provides the opportunity to
increase local traffic and encourages
the use of Motor Vehicles
rather than prioritizing pedestrians and
cyclists the National Public Health
Service Southern supports implementing a
CCTV policy safety and the perception of
feeling safe is important for well-being
the national guidelines for crime
prevention outlines this it is important
that people can feel safe by improving
visibility sight lines and Casual
surveillance building and designing
surveillance is necessary to ensure
safer communities therefore we support
the implementation of a CCT policy to
create safer environments for all in
conclusion the National Public Health
Service do not have a preference over
the financial decisions of council we
strongly recommend adoption of option
two people first s connection we do not
support the proposed option one through
wner place and we support the
implementation of CCTV policy we thank
you for the opportunity to speak nor Oto
C
uh questions
councelors K just given that um autop
Gardens are down below T
Street you spoke about the importance of
the Green Space if you want
to elucidate on why you think that
particular Green Space rather than the
other some what approximate green spaces
yeah is really desirable and beneficial
would you expand on that for me please
well I don't negate the fact that um The
otun Gardens is important to have there
as a green space I think that um
contributing to the urban Landscapes and
Designs by improving green spaces in and
around the city center is important um
and there's been a bit of Research into
that as well and how that is good for
wellbeing yeah thank you for making the
connection
L thank you so your submission would
be that wner place be retained as
pedestrian people first area but
improved yes well I mean in your in The
Proposal um it did have well from my
interpretation of it there were more
green spaces in and around there so
that's why I mentioned it um in the
submission as well um I think uh
creating yeah it's all about creating a
supportive environment that brings
people together um and yes I felt that
option too best suited that um so I
don't necessarily have any comment on
improvements necessarily but yeah thank
you
Ry all right
H do you think having more here or
scheduled events here regularly would
attract people in
specifically yeah I think that um the
the thing is is that it's all about what
you create of the environment it's um
and that's kind of what I emphasized at
the start as we create the environment
that we operate and work in and so I
would say yes creating more events there
would um likely bring people together
and make it a positive
space
Tom hi I I was interested in your
comment about um climate change and the
fact that you know yet another road is
not necessarily the wisest thing of
course and there will be a question at
the end of course the the um the the
hotel is there people have got to arrive
at it somehow and I think our thinking
to the extent we thought about our all
was it's better to ride by bus than by
any other means of Transport cuz people
are going to get there somehow haven't
they so you know way comment on that I
mean I think one of the aims of um of
the whole climate change U mitigation
movement would be to try to move people
on buses rather than if everybody R by
car mhm um yes so we promote um active
and public transport because like you're
saying um it is a way that we can
mitigate emissions but I think there are
two other options that you've listed in
that document where you don't need to
create or at least one that you don't
need to create an extra Road and I think
it's the the purpose that there's also
that risk of other cars using it as a as
a road to cut corners and um that's
where the concern would be over
increasing
emissions okay thank you any other
questions no thank you very much
Laura yes you're free thank you thank
you thank
you right who we got now
Louise go
no we
missing and welcome
um thank you I have realized that I'm
arriving here and I'm going to talk
totally on fly which is always a
disaster but anyways I've submitted I
submitted from a backpack room in
denan um only after submitting so I had
no concept the full columns are going
despite having your document in this
plan it's like the full columns are
going and also I don't understand
because the Railway Hotel isn't drawn in
here and I'm going is that a mistake and
someone's told me that Council don't
make make mistakes I can't comment as to
why the railway hotel's not in
there what I feel actually was it Laur
it's like wow she Echoes everything that
I feel if I'd had time I would like to
have tried to get information about the
number of submissions by the public in
our mall development and out of all the
thousands of submissions that you got
what percentage how many articulated
that when we spend 15 50 million we
wanted amenities for us including green
spaces and parks and playgrounds well we
didn't get that we didn't get that there
despite spending rather a lot so now we
have another public space and I've
learned all about mael Walkers um thing
and and and um this Inner City
revitalization plan of old and the
investment we made in the towers which
reading Mr Hurley's Facebook post as to
the meaning I'm going oh I didn't even
knew that they are I'm off on a tangent
so we have a GRE we have a public
amenity with lots of long-term strategic
goals for it that's in our CBD heart and
the O puny I think is amazing but it is
to me distant this is about our CBD and
heart it's about the immunity for the
public for us for the rate payers that
you which in our needs and it's also
about the dollar benefit to us and to
the council and to businesses of getting
the heart right and this is actually a
debate about the intricacies of the
Ingress and egress of people to One
Singular Hotel of which there are three
options all of which getting the green
friendly bus there just by a few meters
difference of hell so the public that Ed
you and I think when they learn the
columns are going when they understand
this um and Mr Clark you're telling us
we might need immunity in O puni Gardens
and sand but I think we want to retain
what we've got wner
place I have heard oh the council was
saying it's not used and actually it is
true and oh and I'm digressing I went
for the first time when I came back from
from toara walked into wner place and I
stood at the back I actually stood on
the stage I've never stood there and I
realized oh way cool it slopes it slopes
downwards and it isn't truly I can Echo
Mr Hurley like I stood there on a on a
bris cool evening and when I went to the
stage and my friend and I walked through
I was going oh it's cold and I was said
oh it was actually calm and we went back
and I can tell you for a fact it was
calm and I think also it's been said
that when there's been the nightm market
and the other E Street it's like the
organizers Park the Caravans there to
create shelter so we do have a very cool
Amity why is it not used people have
argued for Green Space it's actually I
think so my thing is whatever you decide
make use of it before you knock the
columns down and get rid of it how about
enhancing it enhance it so it's not
actually got the right people need some
of the money for the 14 million rugby
seats for occasional use what about
updating the seats the trees have
actually they are pretty amazing now
it's actually a green space but not
green people want to sit they want to
congregate it's um but it's you need to
enhance and Foster it's not best used by
people because it's not connected
somehow and lower es revitalization can
do that you need green you need seats
and also Council needs to use it I've
learned you have a wizzing new venue
manager that seems to have a lot of
energy and uh vision and he is doing
some amazing things first Friday at the
Civic Theater at the Scottish Hall he's
brought energy to managing revitalizing
that I I would like you please to
tomorrow this week this month please
give him responsibility give his he's
young he's got energy um he hasn't got
the dollars but just say hey put your
oversight there's never been any over it
by Council to bring us the events that
draw us there the um occasionally Angel
which is the Arts the what do you call
it the Arts Festival but but council's
actually not best used it either so
anyways now we talk about you and Mr
Thompson and he's a hotelier he does I
realize this he does not actually
Express the needs of his guests we don't
know I don't know you don't don't know
and he doesn't know he's in an office
he's a developer and concerned about the
bricks and mortar isn't he in consense
he's not even the staff that serve the
grass yes so after they're in the door
what do they want what do we want as a
city for these people that stay at that
hotel but also langlands and the celvin
and all the motels and I actually
randomly went to Farmers Market and as I
do spoke to strangers getting into my
car cuz I'm kind of going what's
opposite the farmers Market is changing
and is going to you know and I said oh
we sorry we're not from here it's like
oh okay I go oh and I got into a
conversation with them I said I painted
a few sentences I said can I get your
opinion so Random data point from two
Canadians who literally told me they see
oh I better read what I've said um they
said that um their answer was a it was a
resounding pedestrian and they did roll
their eyes PL for buses they said that
everywhere in the world that every that
everywhere all the cities in the world
had realized that pedestrian I was King
that was their words and I'm go oh
excellent and they truly they said they'
driven through inago City CBD and we've
been looking where to park like not
where to park cuz it's Sunday morning in
this parks for Africa that they they
said we couldn't actually find where it
was we should choose to park where there
was heart and where they come with
little teeny tiny farmers market that
are seeking intimacy and heart and those
pillar they actually are the only thing
that kind of Narrows and give presence
to um our CBD like to me they Define
something and anyways I'm loing losing
my trap now but if you we can get the
right and we your
responsibility your responsibility is to
your residents and it is to getting the
best economic best dollar of formula for
having guests walk out the door into a
pedestrianized lower esque into our
heart with their wallets you want us to
congregate and linger not just park
outside a shop and go you want us to
stay and like oh we have a sandwich and
we talk can we go into another shop it's
this is it's it's not the needs of a
hotelier it's the needs of City visitors
and guests generically and to me it's
there's no debate I think I probably
said yeah and I truly do despite all
this wonderful submission I kind of
rather think that people don't know all
the detail and they Mr Clark I'm going
to be naughty in your Ben
beneficence to bring sculptures and sand
if what in the place goes your legacy
might be for what you take away in a way
because because that's quite profound to
remove that um sorry but I do I do think
that so please enhance and please events
manage um please place this
under a council employee who can oversee
it um I think that and and perhaps um
sorry was it Laura spoke about health
needs but uh social imunity but I'm
wondering whether other agencies like
great south or whoever it is that can
talk about the dollar
benefit of a CBD with
heart thank you so one quick question
for me and it's not about beaches or
sculptures um if we didn't have the
hotel on the other side which we didn't
have
recently if we didn't have the hotel
development on the other side which we
didn't have Rec Rec it's only a recent
thing we still had no activity in Walk
the place but that's what I mean so the
argu that's what I've heard that there
is an argument that because it's not
used remove it well that's that's too
that you could approach that to
everything it's like oh buy rug ah rugby
park how about that you know seriously I
don't I truly don't think that's a good
argument I think we've invested Millions
it's about making it better and making
it enhanced and tweaking it it doesn't
NE that's I think that is not the
argument to REM it even though it's true
it's how do you improve it that's how I
see it let see I think was no you're
fine I'll get to that
everybody Louise is part of the essence
of your
submission that there are plenty
of
access points to the hotel but there is
only one wner place yes that that is a
correct Su
summation and again at the end of the
day in the debate out of the three
options
isn't isn't this actually mostly about
ease of consent of ease of containing
obtaining consent and dollar cost toist
Thompson like in a way like as in it's
not actually is it about the ease to the
guest it's mostly the inconvenience to
the bus
driver I don't I don't actually
literally understand
the the do yeah like all of these just
come for the ease of we actually are
kind of quite lucky that we've already
got the hotel being built we've we've
got it it's this isn't uh prior to that
that if we don't do this we won't get
the hotel I think
it's there are three three options all
achiev we don't have to give away what
in the place of which we've invested
rate pays
Millions we should enance uh D sorry
Louise this is not a question but I
appreciate your passion and the work
that you've done and bringing this to us
thank
you I just got a couple of questions
Lise um you did mention that was it the
first time you've been a walk in a place
oh no it's not the first time walk place
but it's the first time I and myself
have stood on the stage
right yes and faced outwards do
appreciate it's it's not a big space
there so any event that probably had
more than two or 300 people that would
have to be about the limit I'd be
thinking that's a lot of people if you
were in that did you see the food thing
in Dawn Street and yes there would have
been there was thousands here that could
not have been a walk place would you
agree with that that's true but that
doesn't that's like each each event will
have some things will be in Scottish
Hall and some will be in refug so so
that that that's right and we want to
celebrate our mall if you have event
you're going to have thousands
not I a couple hundred I would say there
are hundreds of successful events which
are below the below the 300 that you say
like there is multiple uses of of
busking events and and and actually when
we and I'm similar like I am not the I'm
not that the venue manager or any of
these Community groups
or I'm I'm I don't have that knowledge
of the actual people with the bright
ideas and the energy to organize things
or the or the things that that that the
venue manager could tap into because
it's it's sort of accidental it's been
built but it's never been fostered or
given any Love by Council they've had
bans and things there you see but in
some respects they weren't totally well
you know patronized because if they well
patronized you would have had an issue
once again with with State Highway 6
being right there yeah you know it's not
large the only band I can recall is
occasionally there's been a New Year's
thing that's really like can I think
mostly people want to congregate it's I
can't answer this it may not be these
big events it's it's actually that like
where you see people sitting was on the
green raised bed outside the courthouse
and where you saw them sitting in what
places in the two green areas there I
think the I think it can be made more
inviting and and I just think there's
young people I'm I'm I'm in older
decades now like there are young
people with energy and really neat ideas
stage down es street now being built
sort of about two3 of the way down
towards Cal Street there's a big stage
there and you got the BS of course this
may not necessarily be about the stage I
think it's a congregation point and a
point
of connecting lower esque and Es and
defining defining what these Canadians
say where is our heart like where where
is we don't have an octagam but we sort
of in a way don't we have with this is
it on here this cross-section with war
memorial and columns woo and if we I
don't have the vision but if we can do a
3D of this amazing new um East Street
East with
hopefully a revitalized lower es and a
Railway Hotel and a railway station and
a market maybe the farmers market can go
on that if you can get that whole that's
um we don't have an Octan what in Earth
would come someone come up with that
name and and these Celtic Towers have a
meaning thanks to Mr Hurley on Facebook
and actually um Joe Massie pointed out
the meaning like oh the image of the
Waypoint of the Celtic marari um by the
post office those uh columns we should
be shouting that as a as a that should
be on our brochures and and all of this
is in a it's almost like our own octal
oan our own cting we can like just kind
of make it up and bellish it a bit do an
aial photo or something you know W
what's what's our symbol on a shield or
on a on a on a you know I'm sure we can
someone who's good at graphic design can
do a footprint do do some sort of
footprint that's us out of that shape
and and and the um kind of someone
clever can link in how you've got your
curve of leing string and and the
Heritage buildings we've got in this
small area we kind of need to go like a
real big foot
print thanks L that's what I think sorry
apologies thank you any other
questions no I just thank you thanks
L right we got 10 minute break
than slightly
more
all right I you like shirt okay team I'm
not a short sleeve shirt kind of
guy thank you Al for being quiet okay
Tina so welcome you have about you have
about 10 minutes or so we'll ask you
some questions I want to see a roof put
over wner place I really do and I'm
coming from not just the cult cult side
but I'm looking a lot of our um younger
younger audience as well sort of would
like to see something like bit of Hip
Hop bit of the musos um like make it a
family place for like Friday and
Saturday nights um cuz there's a lot of
crime I noticed around and Things by the
younger ones cuz I think they're bored
the younger ones have kids z but the
middle lot of our teens don't what have
they got to do crime that's you cuz my
daughter's 15 and she's moaning what is
he to
do can't go to kids on CU I'm too old so
okay you've got Sal City who's doing
stuff as well now I'm going to put it
out there I've just launched my own toy
workshop and I'm getting myself out
there I've just started on Sunday I just
launched it and I'd like somewhere where
I could come and just give it a blast
I'm not going to be out of the normal
everyone Associates PO with um cup haker
but I'm not I'm out of the Norm I'm
going out of the norm and I want to
teach the boy to the younger audience to
the ones that the kids like special
needs go into the like arrest homes cuz
we need to use our hands a lot of our
elderly are going to lose lose that I
don't want to see that I want to see
them still able to use their hands be
able to do things bit of crafting you
know but I'm working with po but I'm out
of the norm so po Kaka no that's not me
and I would like to see Wagner place
used more often done by more and cut
this right the the crime down just
please cover it fix the floor up so we
can do a bit of Hip Hop bit of SC may
have a bit of skateboarding there
somewhere you know have seats that can
go back like you can have seats out
seats in you know we got to make our
city we want a young young people to be
in there we want them you don't want
them wandering around doing crime all
the time we need to like get these kids
in there and give them something to look
forward to even make it like a family
thing on Friday and Saturday
nights no alcohol you know make it fun
make these kids go Oh we got this or we
can do this ask the schools like they
can do like schools all have your
culture groups they can get them out
there we have choirs in schools instead
of just having it at the C invite them
say hey we've got this it'll be
something for these kids to really look
forward to and even I said it like
myself I'm out there I'm willing to
teach that old poy too cuz a lot of
people don't I want to take it out of
the norm and put it out there so people
can enjoy it's something we need to have
something different and out of the norm
um so yes I'm going around talking to
different places I've been on my feet
all day today like I'm not well I don't
keep well I have arthritis and
fibromyalgia you wouldn't think it but
what it takes is up here to make that
strong is what I've got to make this
work and I'm I'm I'm hoping you will all
see from my point of view get these
shoes off the streets give them
somewhere to go somewhere to hang like
okay somewhere to hang I know it's in
town but they can do
something like years ago when I was
younger I used to break
dance was we got now hi they call it hip
hop we can do why not set it up have a
stage they can have hip hop comps
you you'll probably see it it will take
off I don't know what you all think but
it's just putting it out there getting
that feel and I think the kids would
actually like it and the families what
about the families we need something for
families but we could get the um schools
to do um like art like I know Aurora
college does art only know that cuz my
daughter's an artist but we could get
the schools to do art choir coer hacker
we've got
heaps these kids these kids are like we
their kids aren't dumb and I hate it
when teachers label them dumb none of
their kids are dumb they have got
something that they're strong in just
like myself I had to get myself took me
10 years to do this here I am I've never
thought I'd sit here in front of them
the city council of
inv someone that used to just
go any just standing here like I am
right
now it's a long way and it's a good rate
I just hope that you take what I say put
it out there and see what everyone else
says CU it's you want people in town
right you want people to come in you've
got the nice mall that you've made I can
tell you now I was skeptical but I'm
gonna eat my words and say it's the best
thing you've ever done congratul pet
yourselves all on the back cuz it's
brilliant it's what andago needed but
now we need to bring it bring that Vibe
bring it into town you're going to get
people from out of town coming in have
something up there on up at um wner
place all the time so we're bringing
people through we what our country
schools bring them into town we need to
get this going so I'm asking I know it
seems a lot for me but I can't say well
we can't have a new roof put a floor a
Missle of a smoother floor in there take
that whatever floor it is in there out
cuz it's rough so we can have a bit of
skateboarding a bit of mixing but have a
roof we need somewhere for the young
ones to go when it's wet like we know
our weers in in Clement
times so we've got our weers we have
four or five seasons in one day but we
want to have fun I want this place to be
fun you've started it now keep it going
please yes some question L thank you so
you're thank you for the submission
you're obviously an Enthusiast for
people activating of walkner
place so how do you how do you see the
guests of the hotel getting to the hotel
and then
getting into the city we've got taxis
we' got buses buses seem to be not too
bad seen where I live down region Street
there's a bus down there but every 45
minutes am I correct is about 45 minutes
roughly so there's we've got ample
buses taxis and Town's not far we've got
like it's full of um motels hotels
whatever you've got the nice one you've
just made in town you get musos in there
they can come across it's not far to to
take the gear and you know we've got
this brilliant Town you've made it I've
grown up here all my life I was born in
75 so technically I own McDonald's
that's mine I was born there I was on
the gate on the front in the top second
floor I know where I was even born so
lots of us were born me yeah so yeah
just me but I want to make this you
you've got it semi vibrant right you
wouldn't want you don't want to close
off your street so if you open up what a
place what's actually going to happen is
you're going to have a wind tunnel
you've already got a wind tunnel on the
side up on just on the side of your
street there that wind tunnel still
there that's nasty but you don't want to
open up the bottom of your street you've
got it where it is now now you just need
to build to bring it
out thank
you c um just in terms of activating
young people y i freely admit I'm the
wrong person to talk
to there's an impression that young
people don't use walkner Place yeah um
in your
perspective why don't they or do they
and are we
misinformed are they currently using it
it's just a pass by I wouldn't even use
it CU it's open it's wet and it's cold
okay it's got a nice setting yeah on a
hot day is good
but what's there really there happening
there's nothing a lot happening whereas
if you put a roof over it you'll
probably get sit students down there
too it could open up a whole new world
that's the big one so you look at it
with just like think favorite okay FS
the floor at the bottom up think well
you've got s students you got the film
students you've got a whole world there
at s
it that's you could bring them down they
can video or put it live you know what I
me
it's going to open you've already
partially opened up the town like you've
got the bloody good town right so you've
got the new moreall you got everyone
sees a car Park's rubbish full I love it
I parked in that car park and I walk
around
town why am I going to run around and
find a car park when I never find one I
can walk go in there get a car park and
go wandering so you would agree with uh
a submitter earlier who said that part
of the problem was that we didn't
actually uh organize or be proac Ive
about encouraging people to use the
space well yeah yeah kind of like that
yes but if we had a roof over and it was
probably
more how do I say you've got a stage so
you can get up there you can perform do
your thing you know what I mean you need
to have like you want to make it you
want people to come you want to drag
them in you don't want to just have but
like it is now like I wouldn't I don't
really go there I just pass on through
you know if I'm walking screwed through
go to my destination and like the seats
you've got seats there but I'd clean all
that out and make it you've got seats
that can come out but around the outside
so around the outside you can have
permanent seatings so you've got people
that can come and have lunch and you
still got those grass verges on the
outside as well keep those but the rest
of it
goes so You' still got semi-permanent
seat there but there's a whole world
there you just don't realize it's can
open up so much
more we want like you want your families
to use it right you want to make it f
you've got of the Town family friend you
I've seen a lot on your street now
compared to what I have ever
seen come
in other
questions done thank you T thank thank
you than you thank you for listen thank
you thank
you she's great Richard where Richard
is Richard
thank you Mr Mayor and counselors for
the opportunity to have us say on this
area of uh lower W
Street I'll start with option one um I
disagree with it entirely mainly
because Turn the Page over here you've
um got the buses coming off D Street to
go down this street to get to the
hotel the any bus that wants to go down
down to um down e into Calvin down to
EST I should say is uh going to have to
use both lanes of the road to get in
there there's no way a bus can turn that
quick that short short a distance it's
not a not
possibility um I think it's a bad way of
coming about it anyway because it's
going to destroy the whole of walk in
the
place um f you to options
to um they show there that the buses can
come along along 11 Street and Park
parallel to the side of the hotel now
that there's more sensible option
because people coming out of the bus are
going to be coming out of away from the
away from the weather if it's rubbish
weather that we often have here so
they're going to come out the on the
shelter side of the
bus I prefer option two
because it still allows the allows the
walk in the place to be used
um
the I disagree with the clock tower
being being moved quite honestly I think
it's a good place for it there now if
people in the Railway Hotel are having
problems with the noise from the Chimes
well cut the Chimes
off there's no reason why the why the
clocks can't still be used I mean it's
it's a great focal point there and I
mean as someone else pointed out it's a
you got the mechanical mechanical
equipment actually working you can see
it working you know it's :00 CL we've
got in the town now the the um the
triers memorial clock clocks been taken
out and there's a big hole there it
doesn't look right it needs have those
clocks up in there that's that's you
know we've been there forever and a day
well as far as I can remember anyway um
and I mean okay we had problems on
occasionally where they didn't didn't
actually keep keep time the rest of it
but I mean you know there's
no no other clocks in
town the um the
colonades again you look out D Street
and you see the colonades I there's
nothing else there there's nothing else
in town there so they should be kept the
um Clock Tower as I put on my submission
is it um it should stay there but if it
if it's actually Dead Set necessary to
be moved then it should be refurbished
and used again are at the front of the
Civic
administration building here where the
leave Leaves of Grass are if you like
what they call them um and then they
could be go go in front of the museum
new Museum alternatively the clock could
be refurbished and used as part of the
entrance to the new Museum it's it's
another
option the um I go to page two
here
now the
um I'm not I may be dumb I don't know
but um this the this is the council
briefing paper that's come out it's um
got all the plans of rough plans anyway
of how things are going they only show
the rway hotel I had to come in and
actually ask is the Railway Hotel being
is being demolished because it's the way
it shows here it's not it's not on the
plan it's not the car parking building
as part of it
so I just don't quite see how the car
park building is I can see going in the
cars going in there it doesn't show the
cars coming out of it I'm sure there's
some way of it's been planned to do that
but it doesn't sh these on these
drawings any of
them
and the facia for the new car parking
building that's going to be in
there it
should the front the front face face of
it should be uh more in keeping with the
railway
Hotel rather than what's in 11 Street
for the current car parking building
Library car parking building should we
say that's my submissions thank you
excent thank you for that
questions
know right I was going to ask you just
about the if we go to an option that
doesn't involve transport through wner
place can you speak up please I'm out of
hearing
yep me too um if if we go to an option
that doesn't involve transport through
Wagner PL so that's option two or three
um you're suggesting we leave the clock
tower potentially in Walk the place and
what does that look like when when
you're trying to entice people to come
into the inner city like I've been down
there last last couple days in the
construction site and I've looked up and
that clock's pretty imposing from the re
end even if you're tarted up and the
mechanisms are working you don't see
anywhere in the city you just totally
lose sight of it yeah but that's that's
still a clock and you people can I mean
we we ask you see a clock with the
mechanism sure really available to see I
mean okay I mean I look at from engineer
point of view yeah but I mean like like
looking at these things so but other
people walk past there and they they
also stop and look now you know there
been comment made that there's not many
people and walk the place on a nice day
you often see a lot of people sitting
around there you see young people
sitting on the on the um the planter
edges they're having their lunches there
or or you know whatever they bought from
the pizza or the night and day over the
road wherever else they bought it from
they're sitting out there in the sun
watch you know having their meals having
their food so people do use it now you
know if you if you take away those
columns again um they're actually a
point for for people to I won't say hide
behind but they there for people to know
that this is where going to cross D
Street and I mean they they look for
fine I got a friend who ABS hates them
that's beside the point I mean I'm sure
that's pretty much a um uh common thing
with people around town some will love
it some will hate them but I think
they're good okay thank
you any further questions H
Tom hi you you written submission in
emphasiz the issue of the wind funneling
yes but you never mentioned it so much
in your so I just wonder if you have you
got some have you got some experience of
that I mean you you know been here a
long time I have been for a long time as
well um I remember when when the uh City
Library was um it went on fire and was
knocked down um but again I mean it's uh
you know it was was I guess it was
always obviously wind tunnel coming
through there wind effect coming through
there but we've changed that now with
what the place now okay Street does
still get very windy let's not argue
with that but I mean it's um lock the
places actually does break up some of
the
wind I mean when you get you know when
you get a wind coming up through into a
narrow area it funnels it and it
actually increases the speed of the
wind if you get someone to break it off
break it up a bit then it
helps so so my question was really
in your experience it
helped in your experience it helped walk
pleas help the honestly I can't remember
what it was like before the walk the
place was there I mean I just know being
I was um uh a pneumatics engineer so I
know about you know forcing forcing a
through narrow narrow um areas you know
um I mean I guess it was always windy
but we've we we've moved on those days
and we put some into shelter a bit why
was what the place completely closed off
it was closed off to try and make it a
more user friendly
area thank
you thank you Mr Chief finally enough
councelor Campbell asked my question
about the wooden tunnel thank
you any other questions
no absolutely done thank you for your
submission thank you
John wherever you
are right
um worship the
coun thank you for the
opportunity um my name is John
M most of you probably know me been
around town for quite a long time been
involved quite a lot of projects in
town um my my submission is quite simple
really um John can you just use the
microphone just for the people that are
online yeah okay
um I was in the '90s I as a member of
the inner city steering committee design
cream which consisted of mallic
Architects mdal Architects Corrs city
council traffic engineering Division and
Landscaping department and we're working
with the city council under the
management of the um city engineer then
Ellen
Bellinger um I sort of read in your
proposals for ES street that the stone
pillars at the intersection of es and D
have not been Incorporated in any of the
proposed
options and may be
demolished um th those pillars were
built as a a result of a hell of a lot
of hard work by a lot of people a lot of
consultation planning and the resource
of our heritage design team city council
and our
funders and it's quite interesting that
I um Bob found a a minute of a meeting
that we attended back in
98 and one comment was that defeature
wall which is the Celtic wall on the
Corner walk the place upgrade and the
columns are all Community costs all
funded by the community so technically
the community people would own those if
they funded and bought them but um there
weren't a that whole development wasn't
direct cost of the weight pay and I
think by memory I think Transit New
Zealand probably contributed a fair bit
of money into the intersection and the
columns as well I think but I'm not sure
how
much um so they weren and same time
we've got a
um a an information and consultation
process chart of what was happening um
the process we went through the number
of meetings we had the number of
discussions presentations Etc at the
time so they weren't just sort of
suddenly appeared
um the the reason given for their
removal I only got one comment in the um
in the um planner's report that was was
this the primary reason why they were
positioned there in the first place in
the first place when we
started there's a six Lane Highway going
through there and I don't if you
remember is town in those days there was
car parks in the middle and it was very
very traffic
orientated um and our sort of challenge
was to soften the soften or make the
crossing from Walk Place which at those
stages uh was hadn't been yet developed
um I don't you know the story how walk
place came about it came about through
fires um the buildings were fired and
demolished and bit of the uh building
that belonged to the post office was
incorporated
and um we sort of in inherited it rather
than planned it but
um but trying to get a very positive
connection between mock the place and
the r the new redeveloped es street with
given The Pedestrian the the the right
away so we looked at lots of options and
you know a lot of places in European
places used um structures to calm
traffic and give pedestrian predominance
so that was a major concept behind the
columns originally was the when The
Pedestrian turned up they didn't feel
like they were crossing a six Lane State
Highway which what it was Prior there if
you notice you cross two lanes have a
spell two
and that was done very
deliberately the
um the over the overline then the um the
overlying approach of the inner city R
development was to recognize their
Heritage that's were trying to remind
people that they do have a Celtic and
Scottish Heritage um and at the same
time um the Mari was also very much a
part of the Heritage from New Zealand
and this approach was established with a
weekly column in the southern to quite
through the construction project so
every week we had a report on about
where we're doing what we're doing how
we're doing it and a lot of interest in
there the the pillars are very much a
part of who we are I think and means of
identifying the place so when you see
the pillars you know you're in the
center of town the best example in Vago
I think is the first church Tower I mean
the first church Tower is superb and you
can see it from a long way away and it's
quite quite um dominant
um and as example um pillars columns
Towers monuments Standing Stones OB all
over the world act as cultural symbols
and place
markers so inago is also city is built
on flat ground and Visually vertical
structures add character add Dimension
to the uh to the
landscape the pre-cast concrete wall on
the corner was built as a means to
provide some shelter and Clos the fourth
corner of the intersection I don't if
you remember it used to be another Bank
building there in the cable Chambers I
think it was
called got
demolished got demolished made up five
anyway um so it was designed to like
fill the the fourth section of fourth
corner of the intersection around the
monument because there's three historic
buildings on the other three corners so
were quite deliberate and then um then
we had
cultural symbolism embedded into the
wall you know we put the Celtic cross we
put the Wales tail and the zigarette and
they U signs of different the Mary Mary
carvings and a thing on the bottom which
represents um movement of the tide and
the Sea um in a very similar way to all
their predecessors um carved cultural
symbols on stone structures all over the
world
you um I think it's important to
understand that you know with Urban
Design Urban Development from the
past and and to incorporate them into
the future now we went to awful lot of
trouble to establish um some very
critical
elements uh researched them well
consulted well and then we find that um
sort of suddenly they're just going to
be removed and we thought you know why
um we think it's important to keep
things to grow Our Heritage you know
we've kept the we've kept the water
tower we've kept cfic theater we've kep
a lot of historic buildings and things
in the carg so basically um I can really
see no reasons in the proposals to
demolish the pillars and I think they
should be celebrated and incorporated
into our future and become a permanent
part of our Reb
landscape um I've also said I support
the submission by
Bob principle with what we're talking
about with the so so I mean I consider
it's important to provide a sheltered
access to the new
hotel um and the exposed location and i
would support you know traffic
movements through air Street West
similar to what's been developed in the
new Air Street more you know with the
quiet quiet movement of traffic and slow
and and not to you know roiding and the
and the pedest S of quite quite
integrated yeah the in City the in City
development actually won an
architectural
award and received very positive
comments from the architect s e who was
down here on the jury at the time about
the relationship of the pillars to the
general landscape
so thank
you just one quick question for me John
I didn't pick up which which option you
preferred um um having having a a bus
coming in from the south y on a in a
quiet way in the same way as um you've
done in ESS street but I think would be
acceptable now talk to Ross her who's
the he was the traffic engineer from CH
who did this thing they've got a similar
situation in Chri and the square he
working quite successfully for quite a
while so having quiet movements you know
through areas I don't think end of the
world and also think like the the the
clock tower can remain but you demolish
everything on each side of it so the
clock tower just sits in the middle
um we have an issue with wind of course
but you know we can't have it both way I
mean you either have movement or you're
going to have wind and
um and probably walking to place as an
event center is probably not the
preferred option I think it's more place
people move through it you know
restaurants and tables on um foot paths
and things like that and sort of just a
nice good Urban space not the sum of
what you already established across in
in
which was sort of an extension what we
did 25 years ago really so thanks that
Ry um thanks Che uh hi John and it's
great that you're here CU my
questions uh about the original you know
people who were involved 25 years ago
now my question is I'm I'm looking at an
aerial map of wner place looking down
what consideration at the time was given
to the the
buildings west of wner place that were
going to suddenly have this from their
side a wall between them and the rest of
the city were they did obviously did
Council go through some missions and ask
I think I counted nine buildings nine
building owners who all of a sudden used
to be connected to the city and and no
longer so what was talked about at the
time for for the rest of those people I
I think if I remember correctly don't
think the men's building was a
particular you got the menies on one
side and then there's a whole row the
old s and frozen meat I don't think they
were OCC they were occupied they weren't
there was pure office building so were
they just see we'll forget about them or
what what was I just been consulted I
mean yeah we go through the notes
because we consulted everybody yeah I
just just weary that you know we're
looking at something quite dramatic here
that affects people but back at that
time I don't think the TR traffic FL on
the urban the urban interaction from the
buildings on the North side there I
don't think was predominant is probably
what they would have been okay because I
think the South and Frozen me had their
head office in there
MPS lard house in there I think and
there were sort of buildings that sort
of you pack it out the front of them cuz
it soon I mean as far as my age well I'm
not that young but uh it got quite empty
quite quick yeah did yeah and it's been
empty for a long time yeah no that's
thanks lizie thank you Mr Cher John when
do you think the story of the pillars
got forgotten got what
forgotten very very few people seem to
know the history of those pillars well I
think at the time we um you know was
published but then there was built and
people probably just accept them as a
part of the urban landscape I mean mean
even all the all the all the um street
lights went through quite a um lot of
development at the time because um
people s running back to the historic
and those shapes on the front were the
um were the shape of the old original
light poles that were in town and the um
the yachting bit you know I me yachtsman
and and we had a lot of trouble we had
still wanted the Christmas the
decoration wise to go across and in the
old days there were sort of slung off
buildings and they were loose and
pulling brackets out so there were sort
of the whole process that went through
at the time but um I don't know about
the store it's a bit like the Celtic
wall I mean it's there but you know
whether people actually talk about it or
just accept it for what it is
um so you've obviously got a connection
with them and know the story well but do
you feel that there is a general level
of affection for those pillars in in
Bago oh I think there there's been quite
a lot of response lately in social media
I understand I understand the South and
tribute R poll and got quite a positive
response
on about 75% I think from the cost
section so probably one of those things
that people just take for granted and
because they work you know they're just
a passive element that softens that
connection between walk the place and Es
um that's what that's what and then they
when when you design something you sort
of look at you know um bit of connection
to your past a bit of connection to the
Future um you know then also provides an
architectural the vertical element
because you know when you see them quite
prominant in the
street thank
you yes c
um John when you worked on the other
part which was the Celtic
panels um we've been talking mostly
about what's going to happen about um
trafficking to the distinction and all
those sorts of things but as part of the
whole cultural narrative that's going on
within the inner city um we've been
looking at we as an e have been looking
at where we locate the todaka Waka story
which is both the landing place for our
canoe our Waka and those of the later
sailing ships and the nearest place to
that that we have sort of available is
between where the Celtic panels are in
wner place because Kmart
occupies the um
South Bank of the aony um and there's
and there's no and there's buildings on
the other side so when you were talking
about all of that was there reference to
that being a meeting place of cultures
or with with because that would be paty
and George too and those ones yeah no
didn't actually I don't recall a
discussion of position of the wer as a
position now okay thank you
um
yeah yeah thanks uh John for your
submission uh yes I was on the inner
city steering committee with you and GF
p and and David Carter they funding from
I just quite pick up what you said but
the funding for 100,000 for the pillars
come from the Community Trust of
Southland it was a gift from them to the
city and I said earlier uh to an earlier
submitter how would you like tubular
tubular lighting LED lighting across the
top like promoting large
events uh like Easter Christmas that
type of thing being an architect what's
your thoughts on that well I mean the I
know one side we had get guest slimes on
top the top of the pillars yes one
concept um no I think LED is something
which is a recent Innovation which can
be used to um quite a lot of Advantage I
mean some of the buildings in Orland are
looking quite superb with um lighting
even though they got to choose the
rightor color of course
um so you know has an opportunity to to
there's something there for us to do
something with them and do it the
correct way to make it stand out like we
are the city of Water and Light Of
course one other thing the price tag on
this walkner place 16 million that seems
a hell of a lot of money to me now just
putting that into
context that's a quarter of the price
that the ilt paid to build the Lang lons
Hotel it just does not Stack Up do
someone put a decimal point in the wrong
place somewhere true or or it's a place
going to have goldplated tiles or
crystal chandeliers I don't know it
sounds a heck of a lot of money and
you've done a lot of big buildings in
your career as an architect what's your
thoughts on the price tag it does sound
a lot um but if you have a look say but
you've done an es Street I mean I just
looking at our original Budget on it we
were 4 million I think and we did the
original We development of street we did
the whole street about four that was 20
years ago but um the finishes and
surfaces are quite
expensive and um you know when we
decided to pay the outside of the
stadium we decided rather than doing we
just used one big area of I mean I think
we had imported Chinese marble uh marble
I think it is outside the stadium but
that was considered you know quite
expensive compared what we have done
before but um that was quite I think you
the furnishes and a stre the concrete
and the and all the the marble
regionally expensive finisher so doesn't
take too long for all that to add up but
it does sound a lot yeah 11 million I'm
sure we could do it yeah thank you very
much any other questions
being done John thank you very much for
your presentation
you
okay
Jane welcome thank
you you tell me if it's if I'm talking
too loud is that about
right long as you speak well into that
microphone with a quiet
voice good afternoon mayor and
counselors
Co
K thank you for this opportunity to
voice my
concerns I want to put forward a
possible scenario in the future fast
forward to a possible
scenario a couple of Travelers step out
of Distinction hotel to explore in Vago
let's find the community Square 10
minutes later they are still looking for
one they ask a pass by oh no we don't
have one oh well let's find the
information
center oh we don't have
one okay so where are the Central Public
Restrooms please ah they disappeared
too let's get out of this wind that is
so strong and so hot and there are no
big trees for
shade that was a possible future
scenario so back to the
present at the moment we are very
fortunate that like the Nether and
Christ Church we have a significant
Central Open Space it has one shelter
and sun shade adjoining restaurants and
space to have food trucks musicians
protests and
celebrations this space
offers a sense of
community or are we going to be left
with just shops and streets and buses
arriving randomly through
airspace a city with no heart and no
soul Lo the place has public toilets and
the lounge a changing room for parents
of young children and a sh that is used
by all sectors of our
community rner place is situated almost
equally between the wehouse K Mar and
inago
Central it gives a focus and unifies our
urban planning and has historical
meaning owing to Mrs wapner's gift to
the
city we have a responsibility to care
for this public gathering and Recreation
space to protect and enhance
it there has been significant pressure
from commercial interests including time
pressure but we have alternative options
that allow us to keep buses out of Ro
Place options two or
three if you allow buses through walkner
Place future counselors and residents
May shake their heads and wonder why you
didn't value and protect this
significant open
space please do not throw away our
community space do not throw it under
the
buses so June one quick question for you
um if if we come to a position where we
don't allow any transport access through
walk in the place
what would we do to walk in the place
because we hear quite a few speakers say
we want to retain the clock or the
Sheltering effect of the clock but when
you look
at that area that shelter area from the
other side where the hotel's going to be
it's not very welcoming for people
wanting to get out and explore the city
is
it
um yes perhaps but I think
that wel the place is situated between
the the IL between the quest between
distinction maybe the Railway Hotel
between these four hotels now guests do
want they've been on the bus for a
surely they want somewhere to go outside
outside not necessarily under a
roof they need somewhere to go and just
sit and
enjoy outside being outside with sun and
shade and I do um accept what you were
saying but I think the value of that
space that if we lose it we've lost it
especially if there is buses through it
and I know that there are suggestions of
perhaps another um space somewhere else
but realistically how far way down the
track would that be and there's no
guarantee that we would get that
so I think that maybe we just need to
think about enhancing wner place um and
I'm sure you've had lots of suggestions
today about doing that and maybe perhaps
on the other side as you say somehow
that can be enhanced that it's attract
more attractive and people may be on
that side whether somehow they can be it
can be advertise that there is this
wonderful wner place on the other
side thank thank you gra ly thank you
June if we went with your preferred
option how do the buses get to the new
hotel 11
Street so coming in from both the
airport and
Queenstown I guess the this whole
exercise really is PRI prioritizing
what's important isn't
it like I guess there is difficulty on
where the buses come and maybe they do
have to do a bit of a
detour but then balancing it up against
losing this open space we've lost that
that's really really
important you know it's very easy to
fill their streets and spaces up with
things and buildings and like open space
is um open space it's getting harder to
come by it's
disappearing can I can I ask you to
comment on the Wind Tunnel effect that
quite a few submitters have pointed out
if we were to
remove the the glass panels and the
clock I think it'd be wonderful if you
kept it I think as I said at the
beginning I think people coming out of
this suction hotel if that's all taken
away they could to be hit by the wind
and you know we do have wind you know
third is the third of the year or half
the year so it's not really very
inviting um if they just see this East
Street full of winds and not much
else at least if they've got somewhere
they can go and know maybe the restrooms
I think it's really important the
restrooms are retained um and maybe they
can be renovated or made it bit more up
Market maybe perhaps I don't know but I
think they be really good to retain them
as well thank
you TR no
sirry h um with living Street coming you
know if a bus was coming to go and do
you think going in alongside the hotel
might
work uh coming from the
yeah yes cuz it would just yesen you
think it would that would be yes and
and you know um well there is going to
be a car pack B so perhaps there can be
some kind of maneuver that the buses are
able to make using the car park as well
like I'm not sure yeah I just don't want
buses through walking the
place any other questions
thank you very much Jane thank you thank
you for your submission thanks
J is here
okay has just going to get okay just
waiting for the last a minute
and councelors for those of you who have
been following along the speaker written
submission um some of you may note the
era that is coming up themma bu
submission does not marry up with the
submission that is showing there as
being from the Chamber of Commerce um
you can find uh Thelma's submission at
page 279 of board boox or on submission
144 so my apologies for that I'm not
quite sure how we've managed to get that
submission so badly wrong but we have
located it and you can find it to read
and thma should be here
shortly
that's Bally you just
that could be painted this could
be
the
page
[Music]
we could do
really
so that's
all
[Music]
be
good
were
people
so much
yeah and story behind how it was
[Music]
located
theie
yeah
you sorry I was was I'm just going to
be
you know it's
like okay team so we've got thurmer
online who's zooming in can't make it
today physically don't worry about the
hair th
on can you hear me speak now yeah speak
a bit
louder can you hear me oops can
everybody hear
us
yes voting on
something very good now we're just
trying to identify whether we can hear
you just
it got the
have they got us on mute you know when I
left Pete years ago I never realized
what it was going to be like when I was
by myself
sale oh God turn the volume
off I think they're working on hearing
us we can hear what you're saying we can
hear
you Peter K speaking can you hear us got
go somewhere else yes Peter think he
would have realized he no he doesn't we
can hear you you she can't hear you well
we
can she
know can you hear us
now
[Music]
hello am I on yes yes we can hear
you we can hear you
the was on the trar used to call
me
I've got no I take shoes off under the
Tre so nobody can see
them
away you lose
you
hear so so I can I can
talk
good
afternoon it's fine we can hear you
speaking but she can't hear
us can I talk to the Council on wner
pleas you she can probably see you clear
can hear me right I I'm a big fan of
walkner place I've been around in theago
it is it was my birthday just a few days
ago and I was
6079 and I've been in inago since I was
six years old I got to know most of the
people here and most of the things that
were happening and know most of the
marries and the Parky hours that are out
in the streets now my what my um walkner
Place submission is that Mrs Mrs Paul
and Mrs wner were
friends and the day that they opened
wner Place Mrs Paul gave me a ring at my
shop and said could I come down Mrs wner
was there but it was pouring with rain
and it was so windy and I had a lot of
customers in so I couldn't but I did go
after work that night and kept in touch
the first time I saw it used was when it
was used by a craft group about a month
later and it with the way it was it's
now got an extra piece on the back of it
to stop the wind coming through it is
just a wind tunnel the wind just rushes
through and um the it it is terrible and
the people will losing all their craft
stuff all all around the thing they
never came back again and then a few
weeks later I asked Ed Paul if we could
have the New Year's Eve party there and
she said to me thma I'm not going to
have the police coming halfway through
the night saying there's a riot at wner
place no you can't so we waited again
until M shadal came and we asked him and
he said certainly we looked after it we
washed it we cleaned it we made sure
everything was perfect when we went in
and when when we came out but it was
still a wind
tner quite bad of the wind and I fear
for whoever wants to take the out where
the clock is and put the put buses in
there that is going to absolutely wreck
all the work that's been done in esk
street it's because the wind just
screams through there and twice or three
times I read in the paper in uh the
times that you could no longer walk past
their their um place because of the wind
as well and well that's now gone but it
still means that um it's going to be
very windy there is a lot of um things
that could be done with walkner
place the uh the clock is is come back
from the grand ages my brother who
worked for Bond contract and worked on
that clock for years and I and he's
retired now and I'm sure if you wanted
the to go again you could ring him
up and I'm sure he' come down for nion
and and get it going for you because it
only ever stopped after the the man from
the Railway Station Hotel wanted it to
Clos down because it was annoying his
customers you cannot shift
stuff onto other people when when um
money has been given to you it should be
uh it should stay because it's just like
if I wanted to leave some money to the
council now
um I would hope that in years to come if
if there was enough that that it could
be used but in Mrs W's place you've
decided or somebody's decided that her
her
um place needs to go which is very
poor we could work on walkner place and
do a lot with it we've been paying for
it for years and I believe it's not his
his to say it's not yours to say it's
the rate payers who say is this place
going and I think don't really think
that the rate payers have really got
something through the mailbox or with
their with their letters with their
rights asking or doing the things that
some of these things that you have
brought up that you want to do it's um
it's got to be the right payers because
when you're gone and dead and buried
like
me let let the rate payers know what
they're in for so they can carry on with
it I think walkner Place could be an
asset it is windy it'll always be windy
you would only have to stand over by the
railway station and see exactly what
happens the man who's bought the mens's
building must have known this before he
bought it and if he didn't well well I'm
not sure why but I don't want to see Mrs
wner with no family and no nobody here
to support her now her donation go to
nowhere because if that happens when the
donations come in when they do
occasionally come in the people leave
things to the council well it to me it's
just a waste of time because there's
nobody there that really cares enough to
let it stay there yeah if if you want to
use it later on well just kick them out
and and and start with something else
and and I don't think that's
fair Mrs Wagner was so uh Happy the day
that that we went to vickory court and
took her out she was 103 at that stage
and we were allowed her out for an hour
we brought her into town we drove up
onto walk a
place uh and the first thing she said
where's my plaque
gone because the wner place had just
been painted and they hadn't put back
wner place I spoke to C Mr Pagan and he
had it up in a few days but she really
loved that place and she really wanted
it for the for the kids and what have
you and when we had our 2,000 year with
uh the walkner place thing we had we had
the
Millennium we had thousands of people
there we had
nowhere to
um to have the fireworks and as I was on
the trust for with um with the licing
trust I talked to Gary mu who went in
the end because the people wouldn't let
us use the puny Creek but we used the
puny Creek and put boards up around uh
the new world the the um old RSA thing
that they had there and it was
absolutely thing and of course it was
also the year of a y 2K bug thing and
the licing trust I don't know where they
went but I know the city council went on
to the roof of the city council half
them and they were there to if anything
broke
down and um they watched the fireworks I
know some of them then came down and
went on the bus to BL and watched the
fireworks down there we don't get an
awful lot of money spent on the rate
payers but there was miles and miles and
miles of kids there and and there were
all sorts of kids kids and prams kids
and everything we also had
um um the road closed off like we
usually do every year we've never asked
the licing I never asked the council for
any money at all and the money that we
needed to run it it came from uh
donations from the from the licensing
trust and I would every Christmas for
about two two and a half months I would
make Christmas cakes and we used to
raffle them and I'd make about 30 and
we'd have about 30 raffels that get paid
for everything and there in the and then
in the year of the
2000 um the money was already promised
to another man who was going to do
several other things and we happened to
go to the to the annual general meeting
of the licensing trust and was decided
then that um that the money would come
to us and stay it and we spent every
little bit that that was we felt we
needed it some of the some of the people
came to um breakfast we had breakfast
the Kelvin hotel at 6:00 in the
morning uh to to in the day and the the
dining room was full we never borrowed a
scent off anybody we never Lo loaned
anybody any and or or anything and even
today I have a little smile when I come
into to town at Christmas time because
there two beautiful plastic yellow signs
that usually advertising something in uh
P Street or or down in T Street I paid
for those signs they cost me about5 $500
and something dollar and I loan them to
somebody who never gave them back to me
and it looks like now they finished up
at the council so I might send you a bow
for them but
uh they they were they were for the for
the New Year's Eve
party Noby I'm expecting
you said look after Mrs
Noble Mrs Mrs and and E Paul's wishes
and to leave that there
and maybe we could we could do some
private fundraising to finish off it
finish it off properly please do not let
it go down it'd be a real
shame that's all thank
you can us thank you unfortunately the
um technology wise we've got no way to
hear the counselors so they've asked me
to extend myar thanks for your
submission in your time for coming in
today um if we've got any
follow up
questions you been
[Laughter]
spok back has
spoken done we've just got to receive
the report and the
recommendations so there a as's a final
matter we just got to receive the report
and the uh I'll move that thank you
Barry thank you any suggestions or
discussions around those none warn you
out for the day excellent all those in
favor
carried and we're done know thank you
what we V for you know what you're
voting for you can ask you can ask Li
what's up on the screen keep up with the
Tom receiving the report reing the
submissions too late it's already been
carried you now you put your hand up to
request and if beom useful thanks go the
meeting's over thank you thank
you